the family of a black man killed by
police in an Alabama mall on
Thanksgiving says he was wrongfully shot
they want the release of all the video
from that night police killed a man take
Fitzgerald Bradford junior after two
people were wounded in a shooting at the
mall investigators first said he was
responsible but later said he was likely
not the shooter Hoover police now say at
least one gunman is still at large
mark Strassmann is in Hoover Alabama
with what Bradford's family told him
mark good morning good morning overnight
Bradford Police Bradford was told by
Hoover police here that he had
brandished a gun right before a police
officer shot him the police had
identified him mistakenly as a threat
but his family insists the real reason
that Bradford was shot is that he was
black imagine will be the one trying to
get people out of harm's way
this type of person he was EJ Bradford's
family says police owe them answers and
an apology after their son was
mistakenly identified as a gunman at the
river chase Galleria Mall and shot dead
by a police officer on Thanksgiving
night you shoot first ask questions
later it's backwards my peace of mind
and my quads that light past me take it
from me his father Romantic Bradford
senior is a police officer himself I
know my son always respected the police
and if you gave a command you came
around that corner say freeze drop your
weapon you comply with your water since
Thursday's shooting a local community
has rallied around Bradford's family on
Saturday the family joined about 200
protestors outside the mall demanding
action Benjamin Crump is the family's
attorney the pattern in America is if
there's a good guy we're for good and he
happens to be black police don't see him
as a good guy
you think EJ being black meant that he
was presumed guilty absolutely the
family says releasing body camera video
and surveillance video would help them
heal and could help solve this case what
do you want I want
see the evidence I want to see the video
footage you want the truth yes I won't
the truth I want justice for my father
attorney Ben Crump told us witnesses
said that Bradford had been trying to
help out right before he was shot he was
waving witnesses away from the gunshots
and away from the shooting and that a
police officer then gunned him down they
also say that police officers gave no
verbal commands before opening fire the
police officer who did the shooting has
been placed on administrative leave
Rihanna AJ's mom says she wouldn't wish
that pain on her worst enemy Marc thank
you